biden's a never-ending quest to kill the
fossil fuel industry has consequences
like putting americans out of work and
creating huge tax revenue losses
for states like texas but don't panic
biden's interior secretary nominee
has a plan and it might be as dumb as
telling laid off oil workers to go build
solar panels watch
in 2018 you campaigned on eliminating
oil and gas production in new mexico
and you were specifically asked how you
would make up for the loss of oil and
gas royalties
which the state uses to fund public
schools
and your answer was you would vote to
legalize
cannabis i think the point of that
ranking member was to say that we should
diversify our funding streams
for our education and not just rely on
one
here now karl rowe former george w bush
chief of staff and fox news contributor
so carl is maybe cannabis revenue
one of the better choices that john
kerry was discussing
well let's look at it the the
congresswoman in question is nominee for
the interior department's from new
mexico
new mexico derives two billion dollars
direct oil and gas
taxes to the state revenue generally
used for education
and another 300 million dollars a year
in indirect revenues these are sales
taxes and income taxes
on oil drilling and other services
connected with the energy business
so 2.3 billion dollars a year
from oil and gas revenues in new mexico
this is from the state legislative
finance committee
colorado marijuana taxes last year and
fees totaled 387 million
480 000 so if her plan was in effect for
her home state
the school children of new mexico would
be only about a 1.9 billion dollars
light
now what does this mean new mexico oil
and gas taxes work out to about one
thousand ninety dollars per person in
the state of new mexico
they're about 2.1 million people in new
mexico colorado dope taxes work out to
66.80
per person state has about 5.8 million
people
so the average new mexico resident would
need to smoke
16 times as much dope as the average
colorado in order to generate the lost
revenue
that would be one stone state if you
tell if you if you ask me
no one's going to be able to work at all
if they're if
this is the route that they take and you
have to bring two white boards tonight
to explain that to everybody
really quickly we hear that beto robert
francis o'rourke is back in business in
texas
maybe planning to run for governor we
know that he's her favorite subject so
we wanted to be able to bring you on and
comment on his latest
comeback well he's been planning to run
for governor for the last year
and he he was the captain in charge of
the democratic voter registration and
get out the vote effort
uh they issued an autopsy report this
week saying we don't know how or why
but we lost the voter registration
battle to the republicans who out
registered us by at least
88 000 and we lost to get out the vote
effort they expected that they would win
the senate race that they might carry
the state for biden
that they'd pick up at least three and
perhaps as many as seven
republican congressional seats they got
zero they expected to take the texas
state house representatives they made
absolutely no gains
they lost the center ace by double
digits the president won with a
comfortable reelection
that has been the handiwork of robert
francis o'rourke so how do they reward
that
they say let's run it for governor god
the texas democrats they can't get their
act together i'm looking forward to
seeing robert francis o'rourke
on the campaign trail because he's
already been out there for about a year
and a half
since he lost his dismal race for the
presidency uh
you know nothing succeeds like failure
for him well carl i think he just needs
one more
vanity fair cover saying he's born to do
it and born to be here and he'll make it
yeah i think that's all he needs
the last push absolutely all right i
agree
thank you thank you so much two white
boards tonight lucky yes